[Music]
level up with databinding all right so
when databinding was introduced back in
2015 and i can't read anything so i'll
just do it from here my action was
pretty much what have we done
like expressions inside of xml values
this is kind of nuts but as it turns out
data binding is pretty cool and I just
needed to level up my understanding and
the one thing I love about data binding
is you can actually choose how much you
want it to use so it's kind of the
beginner level you get you know some
immediate benefits like avoiding find
view but ID it's better to start at the
intermediate level you actually get
things like custom binding adapters and
observability while at the expert level
we actually have two-way data binding
and this also allows you to apply
observer ability not only from data to
UI but also in UI to data so first of
all let's get rid of find view by ID
exactly so first we just we need to
enable data binding now all you have to
do to do this is actually set data
binding enabled equals true in your
Gradle file and then you need to put
these little layout wrappers around your
file and you can actually do that in
Android studio automatically now by
using by pulling down from the little
lightbulb icon and saying convert to
data binding layout which is pretty cool
now the binding is actually this object
you get from inflating the layout with
data binding util and you simply set
your attributes and listeners like this
which is pretty cool but honestly you're
never going to use this because you're
actually gonna want to use a real data
binding so let's talk about binding
expressions and in order to do this we
actually have to make data available to
our layout by declaring variables in
this data section of our layout and then
we can use expressions in layout XML
attributes to actually tie that data to
views now expressions are actually
wrapped in curly braces and prefixed by
an @ sign so here are some examples of
data binding expressions like in this
first one we're assigning a text
property to a view model property in
this second one we're using a custom
attribute height of zero and the third
one we're actually using a lambda which
calls what to get to gets past the text
view and calls unlike and in this fourth
one we're actually using a lambda which
calls unlike with a text property of
another view in our layout so you can
actually reference other views and pass
them in which is pretty cool
now to give data binding access to the
view model instance we just set the
binding object like
this after inflating layout so pretty
straightforward and then our view model
is now available to that layout but the
real question is how does this all work
and and the answer of course is that
there is no magic in data bindings but
it does seem like magic and that's
because we have built in binding
adapters that handle almost everything
so with data binding every call of the
framework is actually made in a binding
adapter there's no magic you can
actually see the code and use the
debugger to navigate through it the
first lines in the method are just
checking for changes to only update the
UI if necessary and that last line is
actually the set text we're looking for
and there's lots of adapters provided by
data binding and they make it behave
intelligently and consistently across
all these views now looking at these
source files will help to build your own
custom binding adapters which is really
how things start to get exciting so
let's talk about buying adapters 101 the
adapters annotated with at binding
adapter and takes one or more attribute
names the adapter method takes a view as
the first parameter and use a subclass
of you to restrict it to a specific view
type any additional parameters are then
matched with the datatype of the binding
expressions now they can just adapters
can differ just by data types so you can
also use adapters to override the
behavior for built-in attributes now
this makes all image views load using
Glide with their source parameter set
but you've got to be careful with this
because this is module global so you
might have some really cool side effects
of this you might expect we also could
do a bunch of stuff with advanced
finding adapters so like sometimes that
old value is really important and such
as with a color change listener so if
you used the same parameter type for two
parameters in a row the binding of Pilar
actually passed the old value into the
first one followed by the updated one
and also you can use multiple attributes
which is pretty cool like in this image
view so you can actually define these
multiple attributes here in when you
declare the binding adapter and then
those are both available to your code
actually as you're looking at it now
observer ability is also pretty cool and
we can actually use live data to
automatically do observation so this is
pretty cool what we're actually only
exposing an immutable class here with an
example of this and the backing field
can either be immutable or mediator live
data and then you just expose a live
data using Cotton's getters to tax and
then you need to do way more additional
change you actually need to set the
lifecycle owner so you can observe the
live data in your view model with the
correct scope
all right finally two-way data-binding
and honestly this is really trivial when
you're actually using live data now you
can of course use one-way data-binding
two ways as in this example of checkbox
but you can actually just use to call
this it with two-way data-binding by
using at equals and the best part of
this is we can actually observe live
data so in this case it's fine to expose
a mutable live data since it can be
modified by our view and then we set the
lifecycle owner and we use the at-at
equals notation for the check box and
that's it to a data binding maybe that's
not so expert after all so to learn more
check out the data binding code lab and
the documentation on developer and
Raycom
[Music]